des polos rouges et bleus sur un
parcours de golf ce mercredi 19
septembre l'esprit de la ryder cup s'est
emparé du golfe
isabella de plaisir à l'occasion de la
première édition de la younger cup
le concept la compétition oppose des
étudiants français et étrangers
rendez vous imaginé et organisé par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
pour martin en personne était la mère
murger commun s'il fallait que j'ai à la
fois des relais au niveau des étudiants
français dont j'ai sollicité les
professeurs des universités
franciliennes et du côté étranger dans
un premier temps j'essayais d'avoir des
relais auprès des écoles britanniques
américaines de la région parisienne
au total quatorze joueurs lui français
six étrangers ont répondu présents pour
ce rendez vous elle se trouve que l'idée
super cool de faire une compétition
juste avant la ryder cup fera voir le
film gad
oui j'aime j'aime bien ça permet de
vivre un peu mieux la ryder cup en veut
plus ensemble voilà c'est génial parmi
les étudiants on retrouvait notamment la
fille de la légende du golf français
jean van de velde joueurs sur la ryder
cup en 1999 étant franco suisse
alexandre a enfilé le temps d'une
journée le polo des états unis et non
pas de l'europe comme son père ça me
fait un peu bizarre je pense que mon
père va être grand mère
après les matches la journée s'est
terminée au club house par un quiz sur
la ryder cup les deux équipes ont dû se
creuser les méninges pour répondre à une
dizaine de questions de culture générale
sur la compétition dans la mesure où cet
événement est porté par l'université il
fallait qu'il ait une petite connotation
donc culturelle
voilà donc on a essayé de mêler culture
et sport la compétition s'est clôturé ce
jeudi 20 septembre au golf de jardy à
vaucresson
une deuxième édition pourrait être
organisé dans deux ans lors d'une
prochaine ryder cup